um
thanks for having me back on the show i
appreciate it
mariah winter welcome back for round two
i'm so happy to be here man you know i
don't feel like we covered enough last
time so
here we are
here
so good to be you know synchronized and
in sync
synchronicity plays a huge role in why
we re-met
um yes it does
we also did just produce a great video
together it's called what is reality you
can watch that
on our channel now go check that out oh
yeah be sure to put uh you know some
comments we'd love to
view those live and um you know
you can add some body movements yeah
this is what everybody's gonna be doing
at the holiday parties
oh look at
this one i'm just moving it around up
top
okay for those who don't know this is
called stumps
and you just you were
this is fate this arm is so you take
your arm out of the sleeve
it's great for kids it's great for kids
you
and adults that know how to be free yeah
yeah exactly
this is infinity in your sauce go to
infinity yourself yeah
and you just you know pump up and bring
it down to enhance the effect
you can just do it like this but you
know i also like the
oh yeah stir the pot
see stomach hands ah holy cow
all right it's a funny it's a funny one
it's a good one here
shall we it's a little
don't anybody be asking
any questions about my pre-op about my
occupation
we had some comments about mariah
all right boom all right
stomach hands complete stomach hands
[Laughter]
which is really it's one of the oh yeah
just that
it's one of the many
ways to infinity yourself yeah
there's that you know cartwheels um
cartwheels
somersaults dancing we've we while we
were making the video today
we took like two breaks to just kind of
like beat box and dance and play
and just you know be
yeah it only took us six hours to do
which was pretty impressive yeah
starting from scratch
starting from scratch bare bones bare
bones
like prep having an intention but
ultimately
not having anything planned or prepped
but
kind of seeing what was created from
that yeah
just knowing that we wanted to make
something around what is reality
in a way that was relatable in a way
that got people
excited or further inquired into what
the nature of reality is and
maybe drove home a little bit of the
feelings around
self-realization around how we are god
we are
source we are infinity expressing itself
and how
the more that we recognize that we share
our our being
you know that is love and then there's
never you don't
you can never have the tendency come to
ever
cause any harm onto another because it's
actually the self so
there's incredibly important um morale
upgrades that occur from this
realization
also it's it's um anything that gets you
to ask any
type of bigger questions whether that be
what is reality or just
you know where do i come from who am i
anything that can inspire
that because as i had just seen
a ted talk that you did however what
two years ago yeah two years ago and you
know the end of it was
something along the lines of like ask
bigger questions to get your
breakthrough
and yeah anything and i totally agree
with that you know it takes
questions that are bigger to be able to
break through
with you know next level yourself next
level and not in like a success
way but just like consciousness way in a
living way
and yeah it kind of helps
gear toward the bigger questions whether
that's what is reality or whatever it
might be
yeah questions that go beyond
the veil of the separate self
and the veil of the ego the veil of
the economic machinery and
the 40-hour work weeks and the money and
the stress
and the illusions of the matrix
subscriptions
and the questions that normally get
people to slowly pierce that veil
go something along the lines of they
follow a line of inquiry around that
those two words know thyself that
delphic maxim
and most people still today especially
in the modern world wonder what that
means in a
sort of self-actualization style of
who am i and what is my purpose here and
that's great
and it usually also leads to people
undergoing some sort of inquiry into the
nature of their own
awareness or consciousness which then
they recognize
is that infinite eternal bliss peace
that
has been here before that will be here
in the future eternally exploring
its creations and then
that realization is usually what anchors
people
in infinity it infinities themselves
and then it makes it so that
the all of the matrix subscriptions just
fade away
and like the unfollows just naturally
happen and it's it's quite
freeing it kind of plays off of that
first episode that
we did together in many ways if you want
to free yourself
know yourself as god know yourself as
source know yourself as the one infinite
creator
and that's the best recipe for
sovereignty and freedom
and like you said like the knowing that
the others
are also you there's a
there's a thing with like cancer cells
what
cancer cells are actually cells that
don't realize that they're a part of the
body
and it's funny like i'd i might be
butchering this whole analogy and what
this is actually about because i tried
to re-listen to this multiple times to
understand it
but cancer cells are actually they don't
realize they're a part of it and
don't know how to receive help from the
part of the body so what they do is they
try to
i can't remember if they like they they
themselves just
they break apart or they die i don't
remember but it's
it's because they're such an isolated
cell
and not realizing that they're connected
to a bigger thing it's oh it's a very
strong analogy
what you're saying right now you know we
did that in that god's brain video we
talked about
tumors and that's what you can think of
as
the neurons as like the humans that are
undergoing pathology and that means
usually
being immersed in the separate self or
the ego and then what happens is
that similarly with a cell is very
similar with a human
is the same depression and anxiety and
anger and resentment and jealousy and
all of the
horrible shame and guilt and all those
negative emotions
are very similar to the pathology that
develops in a cell
in the way of mitochondrial dysfunction
or the unraveling of the telomeres at
the end
of the dna
there's all types of cellular
intracellular communication that dies
out
and that because of that process then
you have
what is typically thought of as you know
we're still trying to figure this out
but the way that you explained it is
quite accurate from what i understand as
well which is that
the cancer cells themselves basically
become
parasitic inside of the body they
there's a
deharmonization of this 30 trillion
cells in the body and then these maybe
thousand or 10 000 cancerous cells that
have formed some sort of a
of a cluster that are then
the immune system tries to send out
these t cells to go and hunt it down and
try and kill it but it can't because
the cancer cells do a really good job at
disguising themselves i think is the
process
and so it's kind of similar like the
egoic levels of consciousness
undergo a process of basically
saying that there is no such thing as
enlightenment or there is no such thing
as me needing to
undergo a process that makes me more
harmonically
be in service to other that type of
thing and and
especially if they're in people that are
in positions of leadership
then we're really in that's most likely
our most
upstream melody that we face i like your
analogy that that analogy is really good
yeah i actually got that from uh zach
bush he's like work i
love zach me too zack bush is really
strong yeah and he's a really good
polymath actually he's
pulled from a lot of different
disciplines and that's why he's
speaks so well exactly yes and like i
like that he's worked with people
like with people like births and then
also with at the end of like
deaths and like seeing that full
spectrum but then he
he's what did the analogy and you can
just type in like zac
bush cancer cells and it'll come up and
he
explains it far more eloquently than i
have ingrained in my mind of how to
regurgitate that
but um i also just find it fascinating
that
the body itself is such it's almost like
a replica of
reality in its own way you know it's
like
how we have all these things that work
together to create you know what word
like
life like us being alive and then if you
zoom out from just us you know all of us
are working together like all these
little cells are
and if one person you know gets so
isolated and then they
you know they're so like by themselves
and they feel so disconnected you know
and they
you know heaven forbid they commit
suicide that also mimics like a
way of like how a cancer cell or just
like a
cell in the body would do cell death
yeah
so it's it's really fascinating to think
like the more i start to look more into
my own health and
body how things inside mimic
yes how things work outside it's almost
like your shirt
yeah actually yeah it's very much the as
above so below
perennial spiritual wisdom
yeah actually the analogy that we're
referencing right now is probably one of
the strongest ones which is to view the
8 billion humans and 10 million species
on the planet as
a single cell organism
and that if you do that and you think of
the
all the different intracellular
communication components
you know if the mitochondria of china is
not communicating well with the ribosome
of the usa
you're going to have pathology and so we
make these analogies all the time on the
program
and we made them in high level
perception as well and
analogy has been argued to be the core
of cognition
and it really is in many ways like if
you draw this analogy
it is super awakening and enriching and
if you think about it from a
perspective of consciousness piercing
the veil of reality and awakening to its
own infinity
what happens is that
in order to infinity yourself you
have to recognize that there's more to
life than your ego there's more to life
than you being a separate self
and once you sort of get to that
realization which is usually catalyzed
by suffering
then you're seeking impulse begins
and then you're seeking impulse usually
takes you on a journey
and some people get there in five years
some people get there in 30 years some
people
don't get there in a lifetime some
people
undergo these sudden enlightenments when
they're attending
you know these teachers of non-duality
and whatnot so there's very there's sort
of a
wide array of ways to infinity yourself
but usually what happens is
whether you have one of those light bulb
moments a satori
sometimes it it flickers
you know it flickers like enlightenment
in a sense can flicker
and it sort of shines as you know being
this kind of like
centerless point of awareness and like
you are
infinity expressing itself and you
recognize yourself as that
but it's it's almost as though you kind
of maybe ebb
into like the onion layers
and then you're like nope nope nope i'm
not those onion layers and you go right
back and so then that's like you're
re-baselining you're doing the
repetitions in order for you to
you know basically reside endow or
reside in brahmin reside in god reside
in infinity
and that
that process is the most truest thing
about us
the process of getting the light bulb to
stay on
is the most true thing about us
everything else
is fun and it's also true and it's also
play and it's also
illusory but we need to see it as
illusory
in the sense of it's not what it appears
to be
there's not a multiplicity and diversity
of
objects and people and
there's just one infinite creator
expressing itself in this illusory
fashion
and when we anchor that there's just so
many
moral spiritual ethical pragmatic
well-being even at the level of our
biology
that just maximize our well-being and
our in our family's well-being and
society's well-being our friends
well-being our co-workers well-being
so super pragmatic aspects to infideling
yourself
mm-hmm it's so funny infinity yourself
adding a whole another
dimension to yeah infinity yourself
yeah also there is something to be said
though for
you know when you aren't in
the infinity mode of like being when you
do feel disconnected
you know and like that's a whole
experience of the infinity experience
too
yeah and like yes it is that's something
that
really brings people together it but
although you feel really alone in it
it's kind of like
afterwards after that you have the
moment of becoming
together but it takes almost you
retreating into yourself and being by
yourself to then later on share that
with other people
that experience to infinity that with
them
yes yeah and yeah the having that
it's almost like having the experience
of the physical
while being here you know like yeah the
separateness yeah yeah
yeah and that's that is what we're doing
is you know we
we undergo the process of forgetting
which is the coolest part of
infinity god's source is the fact that
we get to veil
ourselves you know that veil of
forgetting
it's also uh called you know amnesia
and the an amnesia is the remembering
and it's fascinating because there's
like that one creative component to
source is so fascinating that it can
fail itself
that it can create a illusory separation
of itself because it wouldn't be any fun
if you incarnated and knew you were one
with everything it wouldn't make any
sense
you'd be like why are we doing this i
feel like we could have just stayed at
the wherever we started
the duality is perfect the illusory
duality is perfect it's like the most
beautiful aspect to the creativity
of infinity and i would also like to say
that for people that are experiencing
what
you know mariah is referring to and i am
as well here that
there's a there's a tendency to
have a belief or a thought or an emotion
or an opinion of some sort
about suffering or ego
or malevolence or depression or anxiety
as something that is sometimes referred
to as you know i can't get out of
it there's that side of it then there's
also the side of it that
you know usually people that have
transcended it
then look back at it and say i see how
it was in service
to my awakening but in that moment for
that person
the best thing that that person can do
is do their best
to undergo the
process that is with you all the time
which is the perennial
spiritual tradition of meditation and
the breath
in doing that process you create the
pause
and when you create the pause it gives
you a higher
more topological more macro level view
on your life
then you realize that you don't have to
go to the next depressive thought but
you can choose
rather to go to the thought of peace
or bliss or happiness or even just the
thought of
a song that you like is better than a
depressive thought and so that sort of
juxtaposition is a great first step
i also think you know when those moments
because you know
when people do become enlightened they
still have struggles and bad things
happen and loss and all that but
you know realizing then it's like you
can still feel those things
and know that they're real but observe
as an observer be detached and not
identify
and that's hugely important and
something is like you know
negative feelings aren't necessarily
like you have to avoid
because that's a whole thing in itself
but being able to
feel it and just truly feel that
and not wallow in it though and then
observe it see where that's giving you
value
and adding to your overall story you
know and
sometimes that's harder certain times
than others but
that's a part of it's beautiful yeah
that's a beautiful sort of second
step is when you create that pause
and then you move yourself more towards
positive
more creator or manifesto consciousness
away from victim consciousness
what then is good to do is to recognize
that every time that
an emotion that is negative happens to
you
that the best way for you to
handle that is to recognize how it
serves your awakening
and if you sort of allow that
style of perception of the nature of
your reality take over
you'll recognize that every time
something is happening like that that
it's serving your evolution and your
growth
but then it really does disappear it
just truly disappears it's so
fascinating
like even for even when you do get to
these quote like
states of enlightenment when your light
bulb is
is permanently on and not flickering
that you don't even perceive
the duality in the good or the bad
exactly
and that's like that's sort of the
transcendent state of like the absolute
perfection of every single moment of
infinity expressing itself
but so then these are kind of like leaps
like that's a quantum leap
up from what we were talking about a
moment ago with sort of
the pause and the ego but
you kind of become a ninja in a jedi
wizard you can kind of navigate these
levels of being at your
will at a more fluid
rate and you can sort of help engage
with people
at whatever level they're at and that's
kind of what that
emotional intelligence or noon she is
kind of like yeah
that's why it's so important it's it's
so deeply in service to us that seeking
impulse that truth impulse that
self-realization
impulse it has so many well-being
benefits it does it really
it it's a total total process
that's that's to be said and you know
even
depending on how strongly something's
kind of pulling at you
and what's happening it's so easy to be
like i don't [ __ ] understand like
where the enlightenment's coming from
what this is teaching me like
you know you're holding on to how you
thought something should have went so
hard
and you know not realizing that you
don't also
have like you can't ultimately
yes you can create what you want but
being so held on to it
and not surrendered is no attachment
exactly yeah and you know it brings you
back to being
surrendered those moments because
you get to a point where you are just
faced with like i'm just
hands up like yeah this is it and then
from there you see you know no
attachment
in a way and then you can grow and start
to become more of an observer
of your things happening to you and
nothing's good nor bad
observer and experiencer and yep
yeah that's an advanced state so there's
like a
there's a leap up from the
pause and then there's the the
creator or manifesto consciousness
desire
the truth going towards that
the balance of the no attachment the
surrender as you do that
and then sort of the recognition as you
do that over and over and over and over
again
that you actually
have this diamond necklace around your
neck which is the bare pure empty
awareness
or as we reference to in our video what
is reality
it is the paper it's the paper that
all of the words of experience are being
written on
and so then that is sort of this idea of
like okay
witness level consciousness observer
level experience or level consciousness
and that's definitely
that's definitely a huge level up and
then they're sort of
there's it states of
of where the entirety of the experiencer
and experience becomes transcended
in the sense it's just a moment to
moment perfection
and that's just what's happening it's
just a moment to moment perfection
and then it's if you can kind of like
take one more step from that moment to
moment
perfection and just basically
infinity yourself at the absolute
highest
um then in a sense
you're just
one with that and that is
you and you are it at the highest and
it's it's it's strange because you don't
really want to
like if you're like in the middle of
like you're probably you're not quite
like dissolving
when you're like walking on the street
because you have to be mindful of
people that are on the sidewalk and like
crosstalk
and all you know safeties yeah yeah
exactly
so like that's if you're on your own
like couch at home or laying down in
your bed yeah there are definitely these
feelings of dissolving and it's
fascinating but that
essence of like knowing how to ebb from
that
into the physical so that you can
actually [ __ ] walk on the sidewalk
without
you know being oh i'm just
you know non-dual while this car
approaches me it's like
you're about to be no duel about to have
none of that all that's going to go away
because that [ __ ] goodbye kiss that
are you singularly in heaven or whatever
i don't know yeah
that's the essence of the too high we
were referencing that in our
direct path number three video which is
that
there's like a goldilocks zone you know
a lot of
modern day spiritual teachings the old
teachings of like the buddha talk about
the middle path the middle way
um but a lot of the modern day teachers
don't really talk about the difference
between
being too low teachers talk about which
is basically
staying in shadow work or something like
that that seems to be people's favorite
[ __ ]
is like staying in trauma and working on
trauma and working on trauma
it's like [ __ ] get past that yeah
you're done yeah you're done
like move on it's so easy and addicting
to stay there it is like and i was i can
i was totally that person i feel like
for like two years you know it's like
let me like
do the work let me i'm always doing the
work like i'm doing you know what i have
to be doing and like yes there is that
component but at the same time you have
to know that like
you've researched you've done it now
trust yourself and then go out and live
yes you know and like live and
carry that trust in your knowing with
you but
there's more to infinitying yourself
than being stuck there
yeah and you know it's so easy to get
stuck in those little ruts of
like self-help and uncover in the work
and all that and
that's the too low yeah and then now
there's a too high which is the example
that we just described a moment ago
and you can say that there is no such
thing and that it's just infinity
expressing itself but
if you really think about it a little
bit deeper what you'll
understand is that if you want to be a
creative expression of infinity
and you if you have the proclivity to
have a
of an ex
an expression of it that
is able to potentially be in as much
service to others
as possible you don't want to be
non-dual when you're
on the street and there's cars coming by
and
uh well you do but you want to do it
intelligently and there's a way to do it
too high
which there are many other examples of
this but so
there's that sort of goldilocks zone to
sort of
yeah to just explain when you wait when
you were saying about the buddha
middle path yeah the middle way i'm not
i'm
not familiar with you i guess i'm
beautiful curious about it
yeah um 2 500 years ago or so
um got to mabuda was basically seeing
that there was
this polarity in people pursuing
self-realization which was that there
was the
absolute ascetic that would
renounce everything including sometimes
even their body
yeah oh and that's where they would burn
themselves and all this type of [ __ ]
yeah all this type of [ __ ] and then
there's the
other pole which is to stay in the
economic machine or the householder life
yeah and to not have any interest in
what
self-realization is and so that's where
he
talked about the middle path the middle
way and then it
now beyond that is modernity doesn't
really have
an understanding of what you know
synthesis is you know
hegel and a lot of other world-renowned
philosophers
talked about the the thesis the
antithesis
and the synthesis but the in general the
idea of being able to like synthesize
the left and the right politically in
the u.s or science and spirituality or
usa and china or hollywood and la
and so sorry hollywood la and silicon
valley in the bay area
or indigeneity and modernity right
there's all these different sort of
false polarities that exist that you can
synthesize but you have to know
that there's a middle way to sort of
grab the both the benefit of both
and bring them together and because
there is a benefit to
both being ascetic in the sense that
you should learn how to not eat m ms and
go on to pornhub every single night
you should also learn how to
not be
in a state where you think that there's
absolutely nothing for you to do to
become more infinite
which is usually what the polls are is
that there's nothing for me to do
which is in a sense true but it's still
up to you to realize you are infinity if
you haven't realized that
but you just say it and you have no
embodied non-dual awareness
you have no embodied infinite creation
that's occurring
then you're just egoic level
consciousness saying that
there's nothing to seek and then on the
other pole is
that there's the immersion into sensory
pleasure this was another aspect it's
not just asceticism but it's also
sensory pleasures
is the other aspect to this pull of the
buddha's middle way because
there's an over immersion in uh in
sensory
pleasures or there's a immersion
asceticism it's
it's this and then the middle path
between them is
very much like the goldilocks zone which
is kind of like where planet earth is
right earth is in the goldilocks zone
not too far away not too close to the
star
also your
you know your you have this you have
your you know your heart has this
lub dub process the systolic and
diastolic the
um the lungs the inhalation and the
exhalation the blood glucose
uh yeah and so there's all of these
sorts of ways of viewing that the middle
path or this idea of antithesis
uh thesis and synthesis is all over us
poles being synthesized is all over us
yeah it's fascinating just like going
back to the body thing
you know it's like there's like a degree
i was even talking about this earlier
like there's only like a certain degree
that we can stay in within our body
that's either healthy or sick
and that's you know a middle path as
well and that's but that's like more of
a detrimental middle path
and you know there's things to be said
about
balance and then learning that you know
and there's times where being out of
balance helps you get
learn to be back in balance and i
told you yeah oh yeah yeah yeah when we
pendulum swing over into
a pole and then if you know
which is usually what you know everyone
is doing their own unique expression of
infinity but a lot of people don't even
know that that's what's happening so
that they're rooted
in thinking that their pendulum swing is
right
and then that's where you have like
people that are obsessed with the two
polls
of politics in the usa exactly and
they're obsessed with thinking that
they're right
and that's the exact thing that's
holding you back
from uncovering something that is much
more deep and profound about your own
true nature
do you want it or not like do you want
it or not you know
that's the question how bad do you want
to
know your true nature because you're not
an ego you're not a separate self
you're not your name you're not your
nationality you're not the child of your
parents
you're not the role and job that you
have you're not how much money you have
in your bank account
you're not who your partner says you are
or your friends say you are or what
society's tried to subscribe you to
you're none of those things you're
zero of those things you are an
infinite creator that is expressing
itself
and to know that you are absolutely
beautifully
transcendent bliss peace eternity
infinity
is to basically re-baseline yourself to
feeling that every moment of every day
rather than feeling
separate self ego depression anxiety
list all negative emotions here and
that's always trying to knock
on your door like if you're ignoring
it's always going to try to show up and
sometimes just bombard you yes and that
shows up in your circumstances
to re-baseline you or
you know it just even might get you
curious one day of like what is
you know you get to a point in your life
where you don't feel like you're being
fulfilled or you're just kind of like
what is this
actually like what is going on here and
beautiful that's when you start to
awaken yeah yeah
i don't know what happened to that
question i think that question
somehow managed to disappear
more from modernity i don't know if this
is true like
in terms of i'm always interested in
this stat but
in terms of as a percentage of the
population that is alive
so you know if there were
only you know 100 million people alive
a thousand years ago or whatever yeah
that
you know as a percentage of that amount
of people how many people
were curious about the nature of reality
or the nature of consciousness or
of their infinity yeah and then versus
today
as a percentage of the population
because if it's the same
amount if that's like a if that's like a
steady
thing that'd be fascinating if it's
if yeah okay if it's
if it's something that has been
increasing
so if there's more people aware to that
question then that's also fascinating
if there's less that's fascinating and
so i'm
really really curious about that and how
people feel about what the answer to
that is
i think people think that you know
they're
this type of these thoughts and these
ideas have
kind of only maybe happened within you
know however
like the last hundred years or whatever
but they've been going on for ever yeah
so you know
for 4 000 years yeah yeah you know and
that's why
people are trying to answer these
questions through things like whether
that's religion
or you know whatever it might be and
there was even this book i'd
uh it's by like what is it
the shortness of life do you know that
one
okay i can't remember who exactly it's
for imbibe but it was written by a
greek scholar like back in like 1650 or
something the shortness of life
yeah on the shortness of life and you
know you must ask the important
questions right away
yeah because it's [ __ ] compound
interest that's what you get
if you ask when you're 12 you're gonna
get compound interest because by the
time you're 25 you'll be enlightened
but if you ask when you're 60 you're
pretty [ __ ]
yeah um so and if you never ask then
you know good luck you're going to spend
your whole life like a ping-pong ball
in between suffering and anxiety and
malevolence and drugs and depress yeah
all this type of stuff
yeah so is that the general gist is like
that compound interest on asking good
questions early
uh in a way like the the book just kind
of
really it i mean it's asking a lot of
bigger questions but it really
emphasizes you know how
little time you have and like what you
know it's asking a lot of
questions but it's so crazy just because
it's written so long ago but it seems
really contemporary
and it's all it's just really short read
i think it's like
60 to 90 pages but yeah yeah it's
it's something worth checking out uh
because it's really written
in a way that's like just like how i
didn't think people were even thinking
about this stuff back then you know and
it's like
it i'm not doing it justice but
it's uh it's it's worth like taking a
look into
as far as you know somebody getting
curious and
asking it's kind of inner
intermission you probably know what i'm
bringing
oh oh yes yes yeah this is
it's a good thing to bring for this part
of the conversation
yeah because i love this whole analogy i
i picked this up on alice's desk today
and i was like oh look what you got all
this rice
and you should explain what this means
and it's pretty it's pretty jarring to
to here yeah i'm so grateful that you
noticed it because it requires people of
higher sensitivity to notice things like
this because
you know i have this little
tiny travel size listerine bottle
and that you can get for like a dollar
and then you just
rip off the sticker and then you um
drain it or use it and then you
fill it up and
if you can hear that only halfway full
too keep that in mind guys
it's only halfway full what you see in
there are grains of rice
so what i did is i counted out a
thousand grains of rice
and i put them in here and it's only
halfway full
and what i use this for
is i use this as a tool to illustrate to
people
the beauty of
that illusory biological affinity
that we have which is you get about 82
years to live that's why there's a
thousand
grains of rice because you have 30 000
days to live approximately
and that's going to be 30 days in a
month that's going to be a thousand
grains of rice so
you have 1 000 grains of rice and each
one of them
is a month of your life that you're
gonna have to live
okay now if you take these and the
example that i usually do with people is
i take these
and i pour them out on a surface in
front of them
and then i say okay so these are all the
months that you have to live
and then i take usually like a card of
some sort and then i divide
the whole pile of a thousand into three
piles and so you have one pile which is
sleep
so you're gonna sleep for a third of
your life so that's a third of them are
moved over
to the side now you have this pile of
two thirds left
now imagine if you do something that you
don't
like for work that means a third
of that last pile of just two-thirds is
going to go to something that you don't
like doing every day
that's [ __ ] horrible that means out
of the 30 000 total days you're going to
spend somewhere probably
less than 10 000 days doing things that
you like
and that's really bad so you should
absolutely do
everything in your possible space of
existence
to do what you love
in that pile of work that you're going
to spend a third of your life doing like
for me
for example with this show um
i i've gotten to the point where
zero percent of this feels like work
zero percent
this is completely merged into my
expression of infinity
and i'm extremely
grateful and blissful and peaceful
because of of that like if you once you
if you have a dichotomy between
work and life do your best as soon as
possible to do something that you love
so much for work that you feel like
you're in flow all the time and that
there's no dichotomy anymore
yeah and it's it's interest once that
also takes you
knowing you know who you truly are and
getting to
that space because then those it will
start unlocking so much more of you
because if you
think you know and you're kind of in
this egoic thing it was kind of like
when i was doing music videos thinking
like okay this is what i want to do
but then like i was hitting all these
walls this year with it
and that's you know truth source just
being like this isn't
actually you though like you want this
for the wrong reasons so then once as i
switch
that's when it became you know more like
okay this field
and i started doing more like social
media things and started my own youtube
channel
that's when that felt more flow
and it was starting to work out more and
things were starting to open
up and yeah that's where
you know you if you think you want
something and because i was
totally convinced like this is my
passion this is it this is what i want
to do
like i will do anything you know and
then
all the doors closed like all of them so
i was like
okay uh i guess that's
you know you kind of start thinking like
okay what's what else can i do you know
what other options
and that's when i made that hard turn
into like okay i'm gonna do my own
youtube channel and like start helping
my friends with their social media stuff
and whatever
and that i started to unlock me to
people that had more
fulfillment in themselves and like doing
things that they love and like you know
work that
they'd feel and flow with and then you
become inflow and you start to see that
flow
but if there's not flow there's
something that you're
missing and you need to start answering
little
knocks you know it's it's that's your
sign
of okay maybe i need to take a hard turn
here
yeah mm-hmm yeah and i love the
experiential wisdom that we gain from
the process because then we reflect back
we recognize that whole trajectory and
then we try
and shed this wisdom and sort of help
people you know kind of like in pokemon
it's like the rare candy you know
so like level yourself up you know and
and avoid these traps that are that are
that are there and you're gonna get
these knocks like you say
but one of these like critical things is
that
there's almost like it's in in right now
scientifically it's sort of inexplicable
which is that
what is you know faith and intuition
yeah and like you have to be really
sensitive to faith and intuition to know
about these knocks and to know about
these opportunities and like your
compass
yeah yeah and that's a process in itself
you know because when i
before when i was thinking like i want
to do music videos i was probably stoned
like half the time you know so it's like
obviously
and there's like a time and place but
you know cannabis is good for certain
things but the way i was using it it
wasn't
for like beneficial reasons or whatever
and
that's when you know i'm drowning out
all my noise i'm drowning out
everything that's anything that could be
talking to me
or that i could be feeling and trying to
get to know that language within myself
i was completely disconnecting from you
know because i was so attached to my
idea of something that it's like
i'm just gonna listen to my own voice
and my own ego and not
like anything outward from that you know
that might actually be my truth
that's just like knocking on my door
like crazy because i want to be
acting the way or living the way that i
am if
there wasn't you know if it was true so
getting connected to that is a whole
process and
there's probably going to be some like
crazy [ __ ] that'll have to happen
and you know just some wake-up calls and
if you can reach those wake-up calls
without
suffering god bless you that's great but
um yeah getting in touch with that
language of
truth and knowing yours as a whole yeah
and i especially because the word faith
in a sense has a lot of fascinating
implication on the
process of not only that
self-actualization and that expression
of infinity that you're doing
or that you're expressing
also on the faith in self-realization
because there's sort of these
steps that we undergo which are
they're not exactly places that
rationality
and logic reside reside
or that that they can attain even um
true embodied knowledge which is
veda or gnostic to be that
you need to take what's called like a
super irrational or beyond rational
a more faithful intuitive
landing in infinity like that that
that last sort of notch into
oh [ __ ] okay bear pure
empty awareness is infinite and eternal
rationality in science is gonna take a
while it could
because you know sir roger penrose who
won the nobel prize in physics in 2020
he believes in cyclic cosmology so even
the cutting edge of science
is now starting to be like oh [ __ ] all
these perennial spiritual wisdoms with
the oroboro snake eating his tail thing
holy [ __ ] that's probably true yeah
and so now there's even science is
beginning to be like okay
fine like maybe this awareness or this
consciousness
it's soon i really i have a strong
feeling that
like 20 20s 2030s are going to be
extremely
awakening because we're going to
recognize that it is that bear paper
that is having all of these beautiful
words being
articulated and expressed and that
that that paper is eternal it's infinite
and its nature is bliss peace that's why
saat [ __ ] ananda means existence
consciousness bliss
because that is what you really truly
are not one minute of bliss every day
but 24 hours of bliss every day
can you imagine if out of this
right if you only have even like
an hour of bliss a day which is a
stretch for a lot of people
yeah but if you only have an hour of
bliss piece like how many times during
the day today
did you and i while we were creating the
video
did we basically take moments to
just literally recognize how blissful
and peaceful
our existence was and how what our
co-creation was
and how cool it was to just be alive and
just be
like going on through the process of
witnessing and experiencing this all
and like that's really living exactly
getting to that point
is infinity expressing itself it's
freeing yourself
and like i couldn't imagine like if
you know back like literally completely
different reality like whoever
allen was dude i don't [ __ ] know that
guy
i just straight up don't know that guy
like he is
nowhere near what i am right now yeah
like that was some
completely different human being
that was egoic that was
constrained in a focal point of
existence
that was especially before i had
attended any of the
the meditation retreats that i went on
was a slave
to craving and aversion and suffering
and then
you know when you sort of re-baseline
yourself away from one minute of peace
every day
to one hour of peace every day five
hours of peace every day and then you
self-realize and you become that
infinite bliss peace
then
like that is perfection that is what
this
is inherently and so you know you don't
want to spend this
limited time suffering and yeah yeah
yeah and like living in a way that you
think
i think a lot of like anxiety and just
you know
things that don't feel like why people
don't feel good in their life
is because they're not living their
truth and they're living what other
people
think yes that they should and one thing
i heard somebody say was if you feel
anxiety who
are you trying to please because usually
there's like an element of you're trying
to please somebody else or a group of
people
and you're anxious about but if you were
doing what you actually wanted and
trying to please yourself
then you wouldn't really feel that type
of thing
and that's like getting more in touch
with like your truth and what you should
do
you know like not should do but you know
what
what sort like everybody being connected
and you realizing like your
purpose within that you know you okay
yeah okay we can take a
yeah you can take a
a child session
the old [ __ ] oh i completely forgot
i will not let us forget the borat uh
i think uh you are coughing it is not
covered uh it's more like water
this is this is uh that's funny
i completely forgot about this we were
doing this before we started
okay let's see here
we make very good video today yes oh yes
all right you must have watched the
video
leave a comment please yeah leave a
comment um make it a family and a very
good
sister in cage go yes when she sees
it she sees it so
people at home in video it is great
it is great
we make all countries around the world
very
proud of us yes ufo day
bangladesh big country and video
yeah b country video bangladesh
we live here in little bangladesh in los
angeles
it's very nice and they have very good
food
very smart people and they contribute
lots of stock footage to our yeah
and the comments are so great on
video we have jesus christ making
appearance in comments yes yes we have
within these uh already early comments
on video
we will we will quickly refresh a quick
uh
oh yes okay so
we will what we have for you here is we
have the
uh this is the youtube studio so you can
see
all of our comments that we are getting
across videos yes lots of
it gets hard you get confused how to
talk like that for a long time
i give so many professor baron cohen
because i'm good
i got lost he's genius he's a genius him
and jim carrey and robin williams yes
they're they're just geniuses and um we
have to respect
charlie chaplin we have to respect the
fact that that they know how to do that
and um and yeah we've had a good amount
of
of of of people that have uh enjoyed
some of our um i'm seeing hearts yeah
and there's
we and there's some uh of that comment
about
christ that that you're mentioning which
is funny but
there's boar hat there's let's see what
else can we do that's a fun one
um in terms of i like i did we did
stomach hands i know we did some i can't
that was good
but is there another sort of um familiar
like personality we can try and play the
like the what is reality
character that channel through when i
was on five grams of psilocybin
yup what was that what use
reality what is it
what is it yeah
oh that when you made that video you
were on nice okay that explains
i was not on psilocybin oh
no that was after that character i'm
saying that the character
of the what he loves reality
what is it what is it you know that
character
channeled through while i was on the
heroic dose of psilocybin
so i was literally holding so i'm
literally laying in
i'm i'm laying in bed undergoing this
heroic dose
i'm holding these mudras by yourself
yeah i'm by myself
in darkness it's beautiful wow it's like
such an incredible experience
unbelievably
incredible in awakening i'm holding
these mudras
right these gestures that sort of enable
the
sort of the communication of the field
to really sink sinking to the spirit
and so
i'm just getting like how do you
compress this is what was coming through
is like
how do you compress the
question in a way that
leverages the
comedic characterization
of like infinity expressing itself
in ways that are eccentric and
non-normal
in society and so like you know what eel
is reality you know and there's like all
these different ways to do that and it's
only three [ __ ] words and it's
literally the title of the video we just
published today exactly
and that's why because three words
and you know you can also ask yourself
the question
what is i um
that's another way to sort of get
yourself baselined more towards
self-realization exactly
what is i not who am i
not what am i but who is
the i mm-hmm what is the i truly
and so uh
now within also i just want to i just
want to say this
that there's a supreme
intelligence that is located
within fungi mycelium psilocybin
on our planet they have intelligence of
a billion
plus years they have the
incredible symbiotic
capacity with 95 percent of plants to do
a two-way resource exchange
underground through michael networks
right so i was a big part of high level
perception
and you think about you're like
what like 95
of plants use mycelium
fungi in order to
gain nitrogen phosphorus potassium
water these nutrients and then they
as they make sugar from photosynthesis
give it to fungi
and you're like dude it's like nature's
wi-fi is what they think
nature's wi-fi it's and you know paul
stamets also calls it the neurological
network
of nature so it's crazy that this
intelligence
is basically first of all is illegal
in modern places which is
yeah understandably so to some certain
extent
understandable but also um that
allowing consciousness to undergo
process and by the way stone day
hypothesis is very fascinating that we
actually evolved six million years ago
from chimps thanks to this process
so anyway another important aspect to
this process is that
what happens you have to have a
conceptual map of what to do
because here's the thing
this takes us to what we were talking
about earlier in the episode
which is the idea that if that
seeking impulse is the truest thing
about you
is to pierce the veil of forgetting
and recognize yourself as the one
infinite creator
if that is the truest thing about you
the next question would be
if you've recognized that you want to go
on said journey
what is the quickest path for you to go
on that journey
so not 30 years not 60 years not 30
years not 20 not 10 not even
five it took me probably about five
years of true
dedication to truth non-stop like a
full-time job for it to
really yield like in the last two weeks
for me
and so how can you get there in three
years or two years or one year
and i think what we can do is we can
disseminate
videos like the direct path teachings
that we've been doing for the last
you know week plus now and
sort of beyond that is if you recognize
that
your concepts we talked about this on
our first
episode together on free yourself you
can find the link
for that in the bio highly recommend
watching that we talked about what's
called
we were calling this temporarily like a
diamond framework
right this sort of lattice work of your
core concepts
like 10 chapters
pick what each chapter is called and put
up these like visual graphics of what
goes under each chapter
for what is your core values what you
find most valuable or meaningful
and so in high level perception you saw
one of them was consciousness for me and
another one was infinity and that kind
of stuff so you can pick what yours are
and mariah can pick what hers are and
etc so everyone can pick what theirs is
but your that sort of conceptual
latticeworker framework
is exactly what needs to be quote
visualized and then
augmented by the most efficient
paths to self-realization so
if you're like the reason why i got what
i
got in the last two weeks has a lot to
do
with the fact that i dedicated myself
relentlessly to truth
and hung up a bunch of different
concepts into my framework of
understandings
that then were able to sort of as i kept
learning more and more things
really started clicking at higher levels
and synthesizing
but that wouldn't have happened if i had
not read those thoughts
before like for example
which means the unity of all being the
unity of all existence is a sufi
metaphysic term
i had been using that for a year i've
been using that term
and i understood it as the unity of all
being union of all existence and then i
read william
chidix piece in the ibn arabi society
and that literally happened to me two
weeks ago and i read his piece about
what what means he's one of the most
prominent
interpreters of the sufi metaphysics on
the whole planet
and this guy says that it's not the
unity of all being in existence it's the
unity of all
finding and that means it's eight
billion people
collectively undergoing their own unique
processes of piercing the veil
and finding themselves as the one
infinite creator
and so i literally got into i started i
started my nervous system went into
shock
i started getting i was on that couch i
got into a fetal position
and i started having a panic attack and
um because it finally clicked for me i
had never
thought of that before but the only
reason i got there was because i had
visualized all these things both
scientifically and spiritually i had
hung all these things up in the
latticework
so in order for you to self-realize
faster
in a sense you do you should undergo a
process of like listening
there's like a two hour summary of the
dow to ching available on
on like amazon's audible and
uh like you should have that in your
lattice work
you know you should have people like
roomie in your latticework
you know he compresses into like one or
two lines like the profundity of
the universe how many times did i read
the sentence his poem
you go from room to room looking for the
diamond necklace that is already around
your neck i probably read that
maybe a dozen two dozen times in the
last year
let's say and i never understood it
until you know like 10 days ago two
weeks ago
that was the first time i understood it
so you can literally look at a concept
and hang it up in your lattice work
and not fully fully understand it yeah
truly understand it and then when you do
hit those moments guess what happens
it clicks in because you have that
concept ready to go
but you have to have had the study
period to add it to there
in order for these things to click so we
have to make sort of the path
that is most optimal for people
at least in terms of seeing the entirety
of the buffet and the landscape
and then being able to pick the things
that have the most signal for them to
drill all the way to water
towards self-realization it's a
profoundly important aspect to
you know what my expression of infinity
is
to help with that that's why we have all
these direct path videos now
because it's such a sort of like a like
a
faster way to recognize that the paper
thing
like this [ __ ] is [ __ ] simple dude if
i had
somebody doing this for me like even
five years ago or [ __ ]
10 years ago in high school in middle
school if somebody was telling me this
[ __ ]
in middle school yeah i would be
way better off today
and everyone would be way better off
today if we understood that we
shared the blank paper of awareness and
then now we're all getting
our awareness colored by the words
mm-hmm
it's it's the direct path is
great because it does help direct people
but also like you said you read that
roomy thing like
a dozen times for it to sink in so
it does help people get there but it
might take them like a dozen
times to you know like watch that and
let it sink in and then be like
oh but what's cool is you do
help you know that's a part of their
learning and offering that is
amazing you know because for them they
might have to also then
before that read you know like a part of
a doubt to ching or something else and
having those other realizations first to
then help them
get to their more direct path you know
but being a part of
even like a ring in the ladder for that
for somebody is really beautiful
exactly that's the most in a sense it's
the most meaningful thing that
we can do yeah the most meaningful we
can do is be in true
genuine authentic service to others and
that i also want to say that the
examples with people like ramana
maharshi that's another example
you'd literally like read about ramana
maharshi
read his works read the way that he
taught
uh practice it experientially practice
it
try and understand what the difference
is between the i
thought and the i am or the i
i and you would just read that over and
over
and over and over and over and over and
over again and you'd be like
i'm getting somewhere like with this
process
and and then you have it up in the
latticework
and then that's when you know it's
mixing with all the other things in your
in your seeking mm-hmm yeah and
then that's when you know you get these
moments of these light flickers of
piercing the veil because you've
had those concepts yeah and
they will happen at your divine timing
of one
yeah and then it helps you to then get
to your next veil piercing with
whatever concept that may be you know
that'll send you into that same reaction
of like whoa
you know and that's that'll it just
keeps happening and happening and
happening but
anyway that you can use those
experiences to help
other people you know reach that
that's that's beautiful and that's
giving so many people
value and freedom and helping them to
infinity themselves really
yes yeah that's the entire purpose yeah
because your infinity
infinities everybody exactly that's a
great way to put it
yeah yeah once you reach
god once the journey to god ends the
journey in god it begins
rupert spire has been doing an
incredible job at passing along the
direct path teachings of the advaita
vedanta tradition
and he's also well versed in the sufi
metaphysics but
the notion that you have the seeking
impulse
the notion that once you pierce the veil
the light bulb
stays on of being you know you're now
you're residing in god
you're residing in source you are that
you are infinity
now the way that infinity butterfly
affects
out is a of the highest morality
possible always in genuine authentic
service to others
but also balancing their love with
wisdom
right because you have to know when to
take a step back
gracefully that type of stuff so not be
overzealous and
like martyrdom with love
which is where a lot of people are at
with sort of the
kind of like
uh a little bit of like the social
justice warrior and a little bit of like
the
black lives matter and a little bit of
like the circling culture where we all
have to sit and sort of listen to every
single person talk about their emotions
for an hour
and like uh yeah
anyway so we're not we're not going to
unpack that because it serves a very
specific
point of consciousness evolution it does
and it's fascinating because i've been
there doing that in the stage of like
plurality and then a stage of like
listening to somebody with an ego talk
for an hour or two hours and just be
there
being sensitive and empathizing with
them um
but we also recognize that there are
states beyond that and that we need to
move towards those states beyond that
and not ruminate there
so anyway
now when you're infinity butterflying
affecting
out that essence what's happening is
you're awakening other infiniti in
people
people are recognizing themselves as
that one infinite creator
and it's gorgeous because there's
nothing cooler to do and by the way i've
said this on
one of the direct path videos it's just
that
i would have never considered ever
doing this before it was naturally there
screaming do this yeah because
i didn't get it up until this point up
until two weeks ago
i did not understand the nature of
reality
period i just i understood it somewhat
somewhat like conceptually i understood
nonduality conceptually i
understood unity conceptually understood
the nature of consciousness conceptually
not anchored experientially in my
most raw essence of understanding the
diamond necklace already around my neck
and the infinity and eternity and bliss
peace of that
so as soon as that landed that was my
moment that was my satori
and now i'm you know i'm re-baselining
more and more to keep the light on
but the idea is that now it just came
through it's just like
oh my gosh you now understand how to
pass along the direct path for people
you spent
five years relentlessly pursuing
truth with your soul so that it would
yield so that now
you're able to communicate to other
people the direct way to
self-realization
and so you know that's my role i have a
strong
relationship with my higher self that
i'm constantly working with
that is communicating
with me a understanding that
my whole essence like my
soul angle if you will is to literally
come to planets while they
are at this extremely pivotal
point in their evolution where they're
evolving from
ego to the service to others
to the stage of love and wisdom
and unity and that my
role is to come and
as quickly as possible pierce the veil
that is my exact soul angle role come in
basically survey the landscape of
knowledge of that planet
parse for the most signal about how to
self-realize
relentlessly go to that process
unbelievably as quickly as possible
and i think i i was having this like
intuitive
you know feeling with the higher self
and it was like
i'm curious if i if i beat my high score
because i feel like i did in many ways
like 28 is a pretty solid
like age to have hit like satori
of recognition of the one infinite
creator and so
i want to get gen z and generation alpha
i want to get them here when they're 12.
you know
and so this is kind of like you know
that's what that's what because that's
sort of like
they're incarnating to
get us to not only like quote fourth
density
love level consciousness in service to
other level consciousness but they're
also here to get us
into a state of balancing that out with
wisdom and then living in a state of
perpetual
unity and so
in sort of recognizing where our next
couple of decades are going with these
young
portals of consciousness that have been
come into this
experience that their
to understand what their role is
in that sort of love
wisdom unity light
work makes it
all the more
clear what we right now
can be doing to optimize for the
flourishing
so that's what it's just fascinating how
it just comes and i mean it's kind of
similar with you too in a sense like
you know you know that
once you've made the pivot into doing
your
own creative work across your platforms
it's become so clear the level of
well-being
that you have now in a sense you
are in a deeper more true relationship
with your higher self
of what your true soul essence is
yes definite and you know it might not
i think for different people you know
their way of connecting with that
comes out different you know you yours
comes out and wanting to share
your experience of trying to figure that
out for like
people you know and that's like your
thing is like let me figure this out
for people to then help give them maybe
like a perspective that will awaken them
to something you know and
for other people it's like oh okay i had
that realization but i
also you know like maybe for me you know
it's like i also
like creating the content i do
that you know it's it's just serving in
the sense of like it's feel good there's
some you know information takeaways
but it you know and i kind of leave
people to ask their own questions you
know but
it does serve in a way of like it gives
them an experience within this reality
because at the end of the day
everybody's gonna be on their journey
and asking these questions
and it's great that you want to
contribute to something so personal
to people you know and so personal to
their experience and how they might
define their realities and who they are
where
mine is more contributing to an
experience of like what i create
you know it's like contributing to
experience of feel good and
you know like getting more in touch with
your body and health and
that's like you know all that serves
critical mission critical really
because it all serves that process that
it does it does
yeah the same person that comes and
watches some direct path content
is the same person that wonders well
what is the actual benefits of
consuming carrots yeah exactly which we
went through today
yeah for lunch yeah yeah or even just
watching like
just a sillier video just to laugh you
know and like experience like
a play part of life you know and yeah
also like
you know there are times when you do
need to ask those bigger questions and
really sit down
and be more still with yourself but
there's other times where you just need
to
you know experience goodness and
fun and you know offering that and
sharing that with people is really where
you know that comes out for me but it
it's great to be able to be in these
spaces to create
those things and then be in flow meet up
with people and co-create with them
like you know i come from like a video
director background and i'm doing these
videos then today we got to make
this what is reality video and that's a
co-creation of you
and me like me with visual more heavy
and then you
coming in with the bigger questions and
more directed content so
that's where those co-creations happen
and
it's really cool to see that you know
it's like all these different things
can reside in the same space yes
and you know that's where the book gets
written all together
yes yeah yes playing on what we were
communicating in the what is reality
video because
to view each one of these individual
the link to that video what is reality
is in the bio below highly recommend
watching it it's only it's like
it's less than two minutes yeah um and
like
to realize that okay so each one of us
are
the blank infinite empty pure bear
awareness and that each one of us is
like this page that gets its own unique
experience of words and then what
happens is you stack
these pages one after the other as
mariah and atlas and all these illusory
diversity names that we stack one after
the other
and you stack them and you stack them
and then you sew them together into a
book
and that's what planet earth is exactly
and what we have in common is the fact
that we are all
pages yes but our writing and words
are unique and different yes yes
and then i like how you also mentioned
how the
in a sense like the writing that's on
you know
mariah's page has a lot of writing
that's also like
synergistic with atlas's page
i'm like i literally can't even refer to
myself as atlas anymore
i seriously can't like is it now alan no
rebirth you can call me non-dual
awareness or some [ __ ]
you can call me infinity you know i
don't even know what anymore
i'll just rename you on my phone
yeah we should we need to steal that
back for enlightenment purposes
yes yeah yeah i'm completely serious
like i
can't even call myself atlas i'm serious
um but
yeah so like these words sort of work
together across pages which is what then
the idea of making the what is reality
video happen together
certain people like another way to think
about this is
if you've ever tried to um
if you've ever tried to take information
that's on a
on a windows operating system and open
it up on the mac
operating system
where are you gonna go with this okay so
wait if you take
windows things and you open it on a mac
then you can't because the formatting is
different yeah
and that's the whole point of the point
there's one format i believe it's
exfat that enables you to open the file
across
both got it and so and so in a sense you
want to be
that file format you want to be x fat
x
yeah i want to be whatever yeah no no no
i i like yeah it's like
it's like n nfts for windows and then
h f s or hcs for
for mac and yeah the idea is that those
two can't
open across each other but if it's
formatted as
exfat then it can be opened across both
and so if you're like joseph in the code
of many colors in the
judeo-christian tradition um or
abrahamic tradition
what happens is you're able to engage
with people that are formatted on
windows engage with people formatted on
mac
and you can sort of easily chameleon
consciousness your way
around the whole rung from egoic to
enlightened states of
of being and so i would say that
if you have in a sense
uh awakened yourself to a degree where
the writing
on the page is of
a joseph and the code of many colors
style
expression then it's really easy in a
sense for me to
kind of vibe in with you create that
you know piece content but i can't you
know vibe in
even though i can navigate the spaces of
the ego
i distance myself that's quote the fifth
that's quote fifth density consciousness
which is wisdom well it's like you don't
reside there but you do
have to go to the spaces and speak that
language in order
to help bring that vibration up to where
you
reside you know yes and just also to be
clear
technically it's not like you have to go
there
it's more it's more like um it's more
like
naturally the evolutionary vibratory
ascension process makes it so that
ego is absolutely dissolved and that
it not absolutely across all creation
designs it's not
across some creation designs the service
to sell frequency
beats the service to other frequency and
then that
becomes a hell planet in many ways and
so
the idea that ours is moving more
towards service to other
and the idea that you can sort of
gracefully distance yourself
politely and peacefully and graciously
away from a level of a goal of
consciousness is beautiful
but like you also describe it's also
nice because if somebody is having an
egoic flare-up
if you can gracefully be that oceanic
kind of
infinite like in terms of like flick
over a little bit of like a water bucket
onto their egoic flame
um you actually can
um cause their ego to sort of calm down
and maybe even for the person to
recognize that what the [ __ ] was that i
don't want to be that i don't want to be
that
depressed or angry i don't want to be
yelling right now exactly
and so then that's sort of the beauty
but don't get trapped
in the marty dome of i have to go and be
that everywhere
always yeah um yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's sort of um if the
for those that are interested in in
specifically
what um both myself and um bentino
masaro
uh think are the
sort of most um
highest level disseminations
of what uh the nature of reality is
it's kind of like it's it's in a sense
it's like a phd in metaphysics if you
give it a read
um it's called the law of one
actually i the only
the only other two tabs that i have open
on my computer right now are the law of
one and non-dualism
course yes
infinity yourself for nothing
exactly and i highly recommend checking
this out just a lot of one dot
info and um it's an
absolutely incredible explanation of the
sorts of
densities of the evolution of
consciousness and the infinity
of the nature of our
awareness and what's occurring
and you very much clearly see again
this is brought to us by a six-density
social memory complex that is
transmitting it to us
channeling it to us through um
in this case it's carlo ruckert and so
it's
really profound in the sense that it is
an evolutionary stage that that
you you become more of a social memory
complex
once you get to this fourth density of
consciousness this more service to other
love state of consciousness
because there's no more dishonesty
there's no more
fear there's no more hatred no more
malevolence no more
you see the self in the other very
clearly
and so it's a it becomes a social memory
complex like a collective consciousness
and so what happens is that that
raw had already underwent that process
and
at a six density level teaching us about
what
these metaphysics of consciousness truly
are and the metaphysics of the one
infinite creator that we
are and how we sort of use the process
of awareness
and consciousness to undergo the
explorations and expressions that we're
doing in these different creation
designs
and so go and check it out it's it's
extremely strong
and um there's a really strong synthesis
also right here um it's actually just
called the
the synopsis right here it's just uh
right there some fundamental ideas from
the law of one material
go and check that out so yeah
so yeah what yeah go ahead do it do it
check it out
check it out check it out and check out
the um
the stomach hands oh yeah everybody try
stomach hands especially do it for
children or actually no
just do it for everybody it's not even
yeah yes
this looks like eight
oh it's like what's coming through there
yeah that's nice
now it just looks like it's turning into
something different now it just looks
like
oh um exactly
i feel like a cat you know oh yeah no
that's
oh i just changed that mike's asmr
the mic windscreen so you're good to
i just changed the mic yeah
i feel like uh it says asmring you guys
what does that mean again it's where you
talk really close to them
i don't know what asmr stands for can we
look it up yeah and then
but i know you like make sounds at a
microphone and
it's like autonomous sensory meridian
response
no uh i mean that's probably what it
actually means
but it's like maybe like scratch oh it
is
you youtube videos of people whispering
yeah yeah you like whisper in them
oh watch stimulating videos oh
it's supposed to create a crazy
experience when you do it really close
to the microphone i see
yeah yeah i see i see for sure asmr
episode
did you already do one not yet but i
want to yeah that'd be interesting
i want to do an act like asmr cooking
if you kind of speak to people
really seductively and sensually like
i want you i want
to get you enlightened i want
to enlighten you
let me in your consciousness
yeah see the asmr enlightenment is so
great
it's kind of interesting actually it's
like evolved to the fourth density
service to others service is so
hot service is hot baby it makes me so
you can subscribe to simulations only
fans
[Laughter]
where i talk about enlightenment while
rubbing my pimples
who says he can't mix you know that's
that's some co-creation right there
it's hilarious it's like um you can get
the direct path teachings on youtube
you want to get more of a direct path
and only fans oh
that is the ultimate direct that's once
you skip a few
ones who yeah to get there
in two years instead of five only fancy
it's the best way to go geez
that's ridiculous could you believe that
like i i yeah that's
something so strange it's like you have
to figure out this balance between like
creating a pay wall
on content for me it's strange like
i've never made a pit wall on content
and i never plan to
and i know people that do that are
enlightened which is fascinating they do
and then sort of the reasoning mechanism
is that there's
several one of them is that when people
pay in
for higher access to value what happens
is they almost take it more seriously
that's true which is fascinating there's
that and then two is the fact that when
they contribute to you
monthly you take all of that money and
you just reinvest it in your ability to
make even better
content which i think is such a
fascinating thing so it's something that
i don't
i don't know if i'm being just a little
too
um i think i'm gonna maybe try and
dabble in both in 2021 and beyond we're
already
making curricula that we're going to be
kind of
expressing some for for free and then
some
it's like a freemium model on it and i
think that's kind of interesting due to
those exact reasons that
i mentioned a moment ago people take it
more seriously
and also the scaling
of what you're doing based on the
finances that you get from that process
but also i would be interested in how
many people don't get access to the
teachings because they're paywalled
because they can't afford it that would
be something interesting that's the one
thing that's really
making it for me that makes it so that i
want to continue
they can get it one of the things you
can do is you can make scholarships
which is when you say if you can't
afford this teaching
email us directly give us a little bit
about yourself
and then we'll gladly give you a
membership yeah exactly
stuff like that yeah so that that's a
great thing to explore and just see
how that works you know and how the
people who
do pay for that content respond to it
and even
you know how that also helps grow your
content
that's free too in the way of like you
can contribute more
back into that so yeah it's
it's a value share i think yeah
everybody and it's not necessarily
you know when the intention it's all
about the intention like the intention
isn't to just i'm gonna do this to get
rich it's more like
you know you can offer a more serious
curriculum
and dive deeper into people who really
really want to know that
yeah and then yeah you know it it's to
essentially add more value to you
and to a part of your audience that
might want
more like far more interest that's an
interesting way to put it too
it's really about the intention behind
it yeah yeah that's that's huge
yeah i like that yeah
that's that's usually what a lot of the
great teachings are
about as well is that if the
intentionality behind it is
you know pure service to others yeah
it's exactly
um well let's wrap let's do this
let's let's both close the show rap and
also
rap a little oh lord okay can you just
can you just give me a beat uh sure
enlightenment what the [ __ ]
does it mean
you see enlightenment means that you
awaken
to the one infinite
creator you weren't even [ __ ] up i
your beat was [ __ ] up [ __ ]
let's see hold on a sec let's do let's
let's
let's let's sing i like this okay better
it's like
dedicate yourself to truth
young one to the direct path
you shall find pierce the veil of your
reality
your reality what is it
you will find and you will
find that truth of god of source of the
one
infinite creator and you find it within
you
and the diamond on your neck
it is right there on you
[Music]
[Laughter]
you are already
it but you also must
realize that you are this is the enigma
and the paradox
enigma and the paradox
i love it oh it's so cute was great it
was fun
it's good there's there's a lot of
strong ability
between us
on not only like the play frequency
which is
exceptional but it's also like the
creative frequency of the
like that content today oh just so
[ __ ]
that was great that was good co-creation
just so [ __ ] good
so good and also
if you guys like that what is reality
video and if you like
the creating with mariah
you can find mariah's links in the bio
blow to her youtube channel and her
instagram
you can also support simulation so he
can continue doing cool things like
getting mariah on board to help us out
and
and so there's a lot that we can do like
this one piece of content on what is
reality
can lead us to a lot of other incredible
potential
as we say in rich patrons and in high
level perception that we want to unlock
the funding from the ultra high net
worth families around the planet and
have them
be able to funnel it into solving the
biggest challenges that are happening
around the world in
simulations one of those arms and we
have
many other teams across the planet that
are doing incredible work tackling the
biggest challenges and so
join us join us you can find our links
in the bio below to support us
in that endeavor check us out
check it out
you are it taught from
i'm thirsty you know okay love you all
thanks for tuning in this was a dope
round two
yeah great round two good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
yeah
some optimal stuff to the self
realizations too that was good
okay much love let us know your thoughts
in the comments below we'd love to hear
from you
subscribe if you haven't yet like the
video share it with people that need to
hear this type of stuff
watch the what is reality video links in
the bio below watch episode 1 with
mariah as well links in the bio below
go and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world self-realize
that diamond necklace that is already
around your neck we love you very much
thanks for tuning in we will see you
soon amen
okay okay okay